in this course you will learn how to use
python to automate everyday tasks such
as creating an excel report sending text
messages extracting tables from websites
interacting with websites and more you
will learn how to use a few python
automation libraries over a series of
projects frank andrade created this
course frank is a data scientist and an
experienced teacher make sure to check
the description for a link to the code
and an automation cheat sheet frank
created for this course
okay now let's see how to extract tables
from a website
in python we can use the pandas library
to extract tables from websites like
wikipedia as you can see here so here i
have a list of the simpsons episodes in
wikipedia and we can extract all the
tables that you can see here so we only
need to use the pandas library and i'm
going to show you how to do this right
now so we go here and i'm using jupyter
notebooks right now and to install
pandas first you have to write pip
install pandas so in jupyter notebooks
you have to use this exclamation mark
but if you're using pycharm or the
terminal just write pip install pendants
all right once you install pandas we
have to import it so we write import
pandas and we write spd so pd represents
pandas so first we import this and then
to extract tables from websites we only
have to write pd
dot read underscore html so inside these
parentheses we have to write the link of
the website so here i open quotes and
paste the link of this website which i
copied before and now this is going to
return a list so this list is going to
have multiple tables because here in the
website there are not only one but like
20 tables so we're gonna get like 20
tables in a list so i'm going to name
this list simpsons
so this is my simpsons list and now i
run this and we get these
tables inside this list so let's see
first how many tables are in this
website so here i write land simpsons
and here i run this and we have 23
tables so let's get only the first table
or actually the second because i think
the second is
the one that corresponds to the first
season and as you can see here we have
the second table which corresponds to
the first season of the simpsons so we
have here episode one two three and so
on and if we go here we can verify that
this is the same data so i have here
season one and you can see that is the
same data so we successfully extracted
all the information in this table
now let's perform some basic web
scraping with pandas
web scraping consists in extracting data
from websites so instead of doing it
manually we can automate it with some
web scraping techniques and in this
video we're going to extract csv files
from a url using only pandas so here is
the target website we're going to scrape
and it's this one so this website
contains data about football matches of
different links so here you can see a
lot of links and now i'm going to choose
the first one that says england football
results
and here we're gonna see
some data about premier league and other
leagues that england has and if i want
to download one of these files i will
have to click on any of those and as you
can see here i downloaded that csv file
of the first listed here so this one
corresponds to the season 21 22 and is
from the premier league so
instead of manually downloading each
file we can use a specific pandas method
to read these files from the internet
and also by using the for loop we can
automate this and download all the files
that you can see here so instead of
clicking one by one we can download all
the files listed here so there are a lot
of them
and we can download it just with pandas
and a for loop in python so let's do it
here and now i'm going to show you how
to extract data from a single csv file
from this website
so to do that we have to use the
read underscore csb method so we write
pd
dot read
underscore csv open parenthesis
and we've used this method before but
when we use it we read some data that
was in the folder where we were working
so in the folder where this jupyter
notebook file was located but in this
case we're not going to read anything
inside our computer but we're going to
read data that is in a website so
instead of writing the path of the file
in your computer in this case we're
going to write that link of the file
so here i'm going to show you
this file has a link so if we want to
download we have to make a request to
that link to get that file so i'm going
to show you here i'm going to right
click and now i'm going to copy the link
address so i copy and now i'm going to
paste it here and now i press enter and
let's see what's going to happen so i
press enter and as you can see here
instead of going to the website it
downloaded the file so this means that
this link
contains the data we want to struct so
we're gonna use this link so i'm going
to copy again here
copy i'm gonna make sure this is the
address so copy link address and now go
back here open quotes paste that link
and this is the
link we want to struct because it
contains here that that csv so this
means that this is a csv file and as you
might remember
we read here
csp because we're using the read
underscore csv method
so that's everything you have to do to
read this csv file that is stored in
this website so now i'm going to run
this
and let's see the results so here as you
can see all the data was
read here with a read underscore csv and
it was successfully loaded here so now
i'm going to set here a new variable and
it's going to be called df underscore
premiere
21 and as you can see here this belongs
to that 2122 season because here in the
date it says 2021
and also this is premier league because
the teams belong to the premier league
you may know if you're familiar with
this competition but if you're not it
doesn't matter
so now let's continue so here i'm going
to set this data frame to this variable
so i press ctrl enter
and now i'm going to show here this data
frame that we
saw already
and now i'm going to rename some columns
because some column names aren't so
obvious so maybe you will struggle to
understand what this column means for
example
and i'm going to rename some of them so
let's do it here fast and we also
practice that rename
method so here i'm going to copy here
now i write the name of the data frame
dot rename open parenthesis and now we
want to change the columns so i write
columns
equal to then open the dictionary and
here the key is going to be
let's say we want to change
only the
these two columns so i'm going to tell
you what they mean
so here i can write
the name of the
column we want to change then column
then
the value and now comma and now the
second
key or the second key
value pair
so here
is the second element and now i'm going
to paste this one so here it's
the second you know
this first
fthg stands for
final time home goals so it means all
the goals are scored by the home team so
i'm going to replace this name
with the home underscore
goals
name and here is
final time away goals so i'm going to
write only a way underscore goals
and that's it those are my new names now
to update the column names i'm going to
write in place equal to true
now i run this
and now i'm gonna show this
data frame updated so now this column is
named home underscore goals and this one
is away underscore goals and that's it
in this video we extracted a single csv
file for my url with pandas
all right now i'm going to show you how
to extract tables from pdfs so here i
have a pdf and we're going to track this
table that you can see here so we can
get this in another format for example
i'm going to export this table to a csv
format so i'm going to leave this pdf in
the description so you can also extract
the table from this pdf okay to extract
tables from pdfs we have to install a
library called game load so we open up
the terminal and here we write pip
install game load hyphen pi so you have
to install this but before you install
this library you have to install two
dependencies which are tk so you write
pip install
tk and the other is ghost script so you
have to write pip install go script and
install these two libraries these are
the two requirements before you install
camelot so once you have these libraries
we import game load writing import
came load so we write this and now we
can start using this library so first to
read a pdf we have to use camelot
dot
read underscore pdf and here i'm going
to write the name of this pdf which is
full dot pdf and then i'm going to
specify which page i want in this case i
want the first page and here you can add
another parameter for example here there
is the flavor parameter and this is the
parsing method to use this is set to
lattice by default but in case you
failed to extract the table from your
pdf you can set it to a stream so maybe
with the stream it works much better so
i'm going to leave it with a default
value and now i'm going to set this to a
variable name table so equal to tables
and now let's see what's inside these
tables variables so i print these tables
and now let's see the content so here we
see that we have a table list and we
have n equal to one and this represents
that there is only one table in this
page number one and that's exactly what
we have there is only one table in our
pdf so great now let's export this table
to a csv file so to do that we have to
write tables that export and then
write the name of the csv file we want
to export to so right foo that's csv
and this is just a name i'm writing
right now and now i set the format to
csv
and then set compress equal to true okay
now in case you have many tables you
want to pick one table in particular in
my case i only have one table so i'm
going to pick the first table and i'm
going to export the first table using
tables with square brackets 0 which
represents the first table so now to csv
and now inside foo that's csv
and with this we export the first table
to a csv file so now we only have to run
this and now in my working directory i
have a new file named full.csv so now
i'm going to check it out and as you can
see here i have the data and here is in
csv format and we can verify that this
is the same data i have before in the
pdf so it's exactly the same but now in
csv format and that's how you struck a
table from a pdf
in this video we'll learn some html
basics that will help us when scraping a
website
html stands for hypertext markup
language and is one of the most basic
tools used to build websites
it defines the meaning and structure of
web content although we're not going to
build a website in this course it's
important for us to get familiar with
the basics of html
this will help us understand the code
behind a website as a result we will be
able to find the best approach to scrape
a website and get the data we want now
let's review the html markup syntax
the first element in purple we see on
screen is a tag
they are hidden keywords within a web
page that define how a web browser must
format and display the content most tags
must have two parts an opening and a
closing part for example
the h1 tag is the opening tag
and h1 with the slash is the closing tag
note that the closing tag has the same
text as the opening tag but has an
additional forward slash character a few
tags like the img tag that stands for
image
are an exception to this rule because
they don't need a closing tag
there are plenty of tag names and will
review the essential tags for web
scraping a bit later the second element
we see is the tag attribute
attributes allow us to customize attack
and are defined within the opening tag
for example the h1 tag contains
an attribute named class attributes are
often assigned a value using the equal
sign the attribute value in this example
is title finally we have the affected
content which is what we usually see in
a website
it can be a text for example like a
title of an article it's cool like that
because it's affected by the tag and
attributes defined so all of this is
known as an html element or node great
so far we've learned some of the basics
of html now it's time to see some of the
most important tag names for web
scraping so let's start with some of the
most common tag names
the first is the head tag this
represents the head section and it's
used mostly for metadata then we have
the body tag
this establishes the body of an html
document and the third html tag you see
on the screen is the header tag
not to be confused with the head tag the
header tag typically contains
introductory content and layout that
goes above the body let's see these
three tags in action in a website that
we're going to scrape later in this
course first let's inspect this website
so right click and select the inspect
button after this you should get the
html code of the website so scroll app
and go to the head tag as you can see on
the screen so this is the head which
doesn't represent anything at all but if
you go to the body you'll see that all
the website will be highlighted in blue
and then if you select the header you'll
see a section of the website highlighted
in blue which is where the logo goes
next we have the article tag this tag is
new in html5
and this tag can be used to contain
block entries
posts etc then we have the p tag which
includes paragraph in an article and
then we have the h1 h2 or h3 tag which
are level headings so h1 is level one
heading which is the headline or title
of a page
and h2 is the level two heading so the
subtitle of a page and so on in this
website we can see the article tag the
h1 tag and the p tag so the first
contains the whole article
and h1 contains the title of that movie
and finally the p tag contains the plot
of the movie the following tags you're
going to see really often when scraping
websites and you should at least
recognize them to find the best way to
scrape a website first there is a div
tag which is a divider or a kind of
generic container then there is the nav
tag which is used for specifying a
navigational region within a document
like the pagination bar then we have the
li attack which represents a list item
with an order list or an order list and
then we have the a tag a for anchor
also known as
hyperlink or simply a link to make an
actual link using the a tag we use the
href attribute for example in this
website we see many movies listed in a
table
we see that this is inside a ul tag
which contains a a tag which is the
anchor
and inside it is the li tag which is the
list item tag as we can see the a tag
has the href attribute that contains the
link that redirects to another page so
now you can see how
they relate to each other in this html
document let's see the last six tags i
listed here
so first we have the button tag
so this one specifies a button that can
be clicked it's commonly used with forms
then we have the table tag that is used
for making tables in an html page
then is that td tag which stands for
table data this represents a data cell
within a table then we have the tr tag
which stands for table row element this
tag defines a row of cells in a table
and then we have the ul
tag which is an ordered list this one is
used with the li tag to make an order
list to see this last text in action
let's check this website that contains
data inside rows in a table so as you
can see here we have the tr tag which
represents row and then we have the td
tab which represents each element of
data then i scroll up and i got the
table tag which is the whole table that
contains a group of data the last tag i
want to show you is the iframe tag
this one makes it possible to embed
another page within a page in html5 this
is known as nested browsing
this iframe thing makes sometimes web
scraping a little tricky so sometimes
you have to switch between one frame to
another frame but that's not in all the
websites so you have to recognize
whether the website you are scraping has
multiple iframes or everything is
contained in just one iframe
before we start writing some code let's
review some html basics first here's the
website we're going to analyze
i chose this website for its simplicity
so you can successfully scrape your
first website
the website has three main
sections the title
the plot description and transcript
now let's have a look at its html code
here i wrote a short html code version
of the website that contains transcripts
of thousands of movies
now if you've never seen html code
before you will still recognize some
text elements like the title description
and transcript
in this case we're looking at the
transcript of the movie titanic so
that's why the title is there
besides that element something you will
always see in html code are tags
tags are those words surrounded by
brackets
there are
opening and closing tags for example in
this html code we have four texts
article h1 p and div
each of them represent a node and we'll
see them in detail in the following tree
structure
the two structure will help us come up
with effective ways to scrape a website
and also will be the foundation for
xpath that we'll use later in this
course now let's start building this
tree the first element of the tree is
the root in this case the root is the
article element
as we've seen in the html code before
this article tag has an attribute called
main article this root element also
contains that h1 tag
that contains at the same time the text
titanic which is the title of the movie
another element inside the root is the p
element in this case this has an
attribute and a text
the attribute is named plot and the text
is the plot description
finally we have the div element this
element has also an attribute called
full script and text with the transcript
of the movie
all the rectangles you see on this tree
are called nodes
every node has exactly one parent except
the root
the h1 node's parent is the article node
siblings are nodes with the same parent
an element node can have zero one or
several children
but attribute and text nodes
have no children
for example p and if have two child
nodes but not type elements
now something very important in this
tree is the attribute element because
they will determine the approach to take
to scrape a website
in this example you see only classes
like main article plot
and full script
however you can also find ids and odors
in this video we'll learn how xpath
works
xpath is key to easily learn web
scraping with selenium and scraping so
let's start
xpath stands for xml path language
xpath is a query language for selecting
nodes from an xml document but we can
also use it to select elements from html
pages another way to select elements
from websites is using css selectors
css stands for cascadian style [ __ ]
so it's a language that was mainly
created to style html web pages css and
xpath have some similarities in their
syntax
however in this course we'll mainly see
how to select elements with xpath
because of its simplicity now let's
review the expat syntax
with xpath we can select an element by
using the double slash and then we write
the element name this is the most basic
way to locate an element or node for
example if you want to select all the h1
elements in an html page we do double
slot
h1
this double slash is a special character
in xpath that means
pick a matching note that is located at
any level within the xml document
we're going to see the meaning of this
in other special characters in detail in
the next video
now we can select an element based on
its position by using the square
brackets
let's imagine that there are two h1 tags
in the page
you will pick the first writing the
expat expression double slash h1 plus
one inside square brackets
and you will pick the second h1 tag with
double slash h1 and the number two
inside square brackets now we can also
specify the attributes adding square
brackets and writing inside the
attribute name
this is the standard version of an
it starts with double slash followed by
the tag name
square brackets the add sign
and the attribute name like class id and
so on then we write that equal sign then
quotation marks and inside the quotation
marks that attribute value
this is how we build an average expat
expression we can also use some
functions to find specific values for
example the startswith function will
search for text at the beginning while
the contain function will search for
text included inside an element in this
example i included that contains
function
inside the xpath expression
so as you can see we have to include
parentheses to wrap the attribute name
and attribute value we also have to use
the comma to separate the attribute name
and attribute value instead of the equal
sign you can also use the end or logical
operators with expat expressions
they should be placed inside the square
brackets and every time you use
operators include a parenthesis for each
xpath expression we'll see how functions
and operators work in action using a
small html code in the next video
now it's time to test some expat
expressions
with this small html code we've been
using so far
i'm gonna leave the html code i'm using
with the link of this website in the
description so you can play with it and
understand how xpath works
so as you can see this is a small html
code of the titanic transcript we've
seen before
so
this
html code is going to help us understand
what we've learned of xpath so far
so as you can see there is the title the
plot description and the small
transcript i wrote
so you can test the expat expression in
that bar for example i'm going to write
double slash and then write the tag name
h1
so as you can see here the result it
includes the h1 that is the title
titanic
1997
and if i want the text i can just write
slash and then text with parentheses
this is one way to get the text but
there are many ways to get text with
selenium or with scraping i'm going to
show you how to do it later so now let's
test some other expat expression so
let's try the p which is the paragraph
tag
so now i write p and i got two results
because i include two plot elements now
let's try double slash div and now let's
get the text inside it so we get the
transcript of this movie which is just a
small
phrase of the movie
and
now let's try some other expression so i
write double slash and p so i get two
results because i have two plots so if i
want to specify one element in
particular i have to open square
brackets and inside i have to write the
number so
for example if i write one it means the
first element or the first p element
which is the first plot that contains 84
years later and if i write two it's the
second plot that contains the text in
the end and that's it
so so now let's write div to test that
average expat expression so now i write
that add sign
and then class
and then
open quotes and write full screen so
this is going to be the expat expression
of the transcript element so this
represents the full script element and
we just
use the expat expression with the div
tag the class attribute name and the
full script attribute value as we've
seen before
so now if i want the text i just write
slash and text with parenthesis and we
just get the text now let's delete all
the text values and just leave the
the sign elements of the expat
expression like the double slash the
quotes square brackets and the add sign
so this is the bones of the expat
expression and now i'm going to write
the p tag
class and now the value plot
so as you can see i get one element
because i just have one expat with these
conditions and now let's test some
logical operators
so to do so i'm going to include
parentheses and then copy this
write or and then paste this expression
so i'm saying
locate an
element that contains the class plot or
the class plot2 so either one or the
other so as you can see in the result i
get two results that tell us that both
elements satisfy these conditions now if
i write and instead of or
i will get no result because there is no
element that satisfies both conditions
so let's now try the contains function
so i delete one expat expression and now
just one remains so i'm going to write
inside the square brackets the word
contains and instead of writing the
equal sign i'm going to replace it with
the comma as you can see it says that at
least it should has two arguments so i'm
going to replace that equal sign with
the comma so as you can see i get two
results because both elements contain
the word plot
inside the attribute name so that's why
i get to results this contains function
will still work if i change the expat
expression so let's change the p tag for
div
and also let's change the plot
attribute value for script so now i get
that transcript element which is the
full script and that's how you use the
contains function with expat expressions
and that's it now it's your turn to test
any xpath you want with this html code
now it's time to see some special
characters that will come in handy when
writing expat
this lesson will be extremely useful to
build robust expat expressions that will
efficiently locate any element we want
first we have the single slash character
this one selects the children from the
node set on the left side of this
character
in contrast the double slash specifies
that the matching note set should be
located at any level within the document
for example if we write double slash
article we'll get any descendant node in
the html tree
in this case the root is the only that
matches
now if i add slash h1 i get the
immediate h1 element in this case the
movie title
if i add
slash p
i get the 2p elements and if i add slash
div i get the transcript on the other
hand if we want to get the text we
should write text and parenthesis
however if we add only a single slash we
won't get the text we want because it's
not the child node of article
so what we have to do is to write first
the element that contains the text
for example if we write slash h1 before
slash text parenthesis we should get the
title
also you can get the text using double
slash text and parenthesis because
double slash locates an element located
at any level within the document
then we have the dot character this
specifies that the current context
should be considered as a reference so
it refers to the present node then we
have the double dots which refers to
apparent nodes sometimes it's difficult
to find an element in a website but if
you find its children you can use this
special character to find the parent now
i have a double slash h1 that matches
the title let's see what happens if i
add single slash and period
as you can see i still get the same
element because period returns the
current node however if i write now
period twice the parent node will be
returned in this case the part note of
h1 is article unfortunately in this
xpath playground page you can see it
clearly but if we go to the actual page
and inspect it then press ctrl f to text
path and write the same x path so first
double slash h1 and then add that twice
you will see that only the article
element that is the parent node will be
highlighted in green
now we have the asterisk character which
is a wild card character that selects
all elements or attributes regardless of
names as an exercise try to guess what
these characters mean together you can
pause the video to figure it out if you
want so these
characters together select all the
children notes considering the current
context this means that all the children
elements will be matched so this is the
opposite of that double dot character
that gives you the parry node now let's
test the asterisk character if i write
double slash article and then slash
asterisk i get all the notes inside
articles so as you can see there is the
h1 node the p node
and the
div node that contains that transcript
now as you can see we obtain all the
elements inside now if i add slash text
parenthesis i get all the text inside
these elements
finally we have some characters we've
already seen
so first there is the add sign which
selects an attribute then we have the
parenthesis that it's used for grouping
and expat expression
and the last one is the square brackets
with the number inside which indicates
that the node with an index n should be
selected and that's it you just learn
many special characters use them wisely
to build better expat expressions
to scrape websites with selenium first
you have to download chrome driver and
install selenium to download chrome
driver just go to
chromedriver.chromium.org
and in the download section you will
find this page
here you will find the current releases
of chrome driver and you have to choose
the one that corresponds to the version
of the google chrome you're using to
know which version is the right for you
just go to this three dots button on the
upper right corner and click on it and
inside help click on about google chrome
here you will see the version of google
chrome that you have installed so in my
case i have installed version 92 so i'm
going back to the other tab and now i'm
going to choose chromedriver92
but in your case you have to choose the
one that corresponds to your chrome
driver so i click on chrome driver 92
then you see options for different
operating systems so you'll see linux
mac and windows in my case i have a mac
so i'm going to download mat64 so i
click on it and then it's going to start
downloading the file once the file is
downloaded unzip the file and remember
the path where you're leaving this file
because we're going to use this path
later now it's time to install selenium
so you can install inside pycharm so
just open python and then go to the
terminal located on the bottom so click
on it
and after that just write pip
install
selenium
and after this just press enter and
after this you'll have selenium install
another way to install selenium is just
opening the terminal or the command
prompt in my case i'm gonna open the
terminal and once you have the terminal
just activate your virtual environment
and then write pip install
selenium
and
press enter and then selenium will be
installed on your machine and that's it
in this video i'm going to show you how
to automate this website so we can
extract
the titles and subtitles that you can
see here in the news so we're going to
struck these titles and subtitles of
each card so we don't have to visit this
website every time we want to read the
news but we only check our txt file
and see the titles and subtitles and we
can see which is the most interesting
news for us so let's go to pycharm and
the first thing we're gonna do is to
create a driver a driver allows us to
interact with this website through
selenium so
let's do this so first we have to import
what driver so we're right from selenium
import
web driver so that's the first thing we
do and after that we have to make
another import so we have to write from
selenium.webdriver.chrome
that service import
service so
in selenium 4 we have to make this extra
import which is something we didn't need
in selenium 3 but for selenium 4 which
we're using right now we need this extra
import so let's continue this
and now let's define the website and the
path that we're using so first the
website
that we're going to automate in this
case is this website i chose
which is all about football and
i just copy and paste it so here's the
website and now the path
so the path is where you downloaded that
chrome driver so in the previous video
you downloaded a chrome driver and you
have to copy and paste the path of that
file so just copy and paste it so i'm
just gonna paste the path of my chrome
driver here and now let's define the
driver so i write driver equal to
webdriver
dot chrome
and open parenthesis
in previous versions of selenium that
was enough to create a driver but on
selenium 4 we have to do an extra step
which is
creating a service so here i'm gonna
write service
equal to and here use this
service that i imported here so i just
copy and paste
and
now i have to
write executable path equal to
path so
this
executable underscore path argument is
equal to the path that we defined here
and after this we have to define the
service parameter
inside this chrome
uh this scroll method and equal to
service
so basically
it's first we define a service
uh we say
executable path equal to path
and then we
uh define here in the service parameter
we set it this equal to surface which is
this one that we defined before and now
we can open a driver by writing
driver.get
and inside parentheses we write website
so
driver.get
website and if we run this
we're gonna open uh
chrome driver or just
the chrome browser as you can see here
here it says that chrome is being
controlled by automated test software
and this is not the browser i had before
the one i opened before that i showed
you before is here so this is the one i
open manually uh with chrome but this
one is one that the one that selenium
opened
by itself so automatically so we're
gonna
automate this uh this website and we're
gonna do that on the next video
all right in this video i'm gonna show
you how to extract the title and
subtitle of this news
so
first to extract that title and the
subtitle and all the data in any website
that you visit you have to right click
on any blog space and select that
inspect option so i select on inspect
and now we have these
developer tools open so this tab that we
just opened is developer tools and here
it contains all the html elements that
is behind this website so you can see
here that we have many elements and they
represent
uh the elements in the website
so now i'm gonna click on this option or
this button on the left
the one that is here and i'm gonna
select a specific element that i want so
here
let's select this element that is here
uh on the right that i'm
i'm hovering on right now so i'm gonna
right click i'm gonna click on this
element that is here
on the left and then i'm gonna drag to
this element that is here so this is a
card of add news and there are many so
i'm going to choose this one in
particular just to work with this so i
click
and now we have this
element in blue so it's selected this in
the developer tools and this indicates
that this is the html element that is
behind this card and as you can see
every card contains a title and a
subtitle
and
this one here too contains a title and a
subtitle and this one the big one here
also a title and a subtitle and now
let's check out other elements here in
the developer tools so
we have now this element in blue but we
can go up and see this div element so we
have before this a element but here we
have now the div element and this one
represents i think the folder of this
news
and if we go up we can see
let's say a small container that only
contains the
title and subtitle and if we go up we
see
the container that only contains that
image of the news
so basically that's how it works and
also here this is the element let's say
the parent element and this one contains
the whole thing
so i'm gonna use this one in particular
to locate this card and not only this
one but all these cards because they
represent or they have the same pattern
so i'm gonna build an expat that locates
this element and to do that we have to
press ctrl f here in developer tools
and once we press this
we have this option that allows us to
find an element by its xpath so here we
have to build the xpath which basically
consists of a tag
attribute and the attribute value and
now let's create this x path so i'm
going to copy the attribute volume
because it's a bit long and i might
forget and now to create this xpath i
only have to write double slash
then the name of the tag which is div
then open square brackets and here i
uh write this add sign and then the name
of the attribute which is class then
equal to
double quotes or single quotes and now i
paste that element that i had before and
as you can see this element is now
highlighted in green
now this is great we have the whole card
selected but on second thought i think
it's much much better if we only select
the text because here now we have not
only the text but we have the image
of the news but we only want the text
because that's what we're going to
extract so
to do that i'm going down here and this
one represents the the image as you can
see here
and i'm going down one more time and
this element represents only the text so
i'm going to replace the value
of this attribute and i'm going to paste
it here so we only obtain that element
and not
the whole thing so
here i paste it and now i have this
element which is well first we have this
one because this is the first element on
the on the website and then we have this
one so this is the one we were working
with and well we also have this one and
this one and by the way here in this
option we can navigate through all the
elements that were found so as you can
see not only this element represents
this x path but also all the news that
you can see in this website
so let's go back to this one and as you
can see here we only have the
title and the subtitle so only the text
great now let's copy this x path and
let's go back to pirate charm and what
i'm going to do is paste this xpath
and now
i'm going to
write
driver dot and here i'm going to use a
method called find element so i choose
this one and
this has two parameters
by
and
also volume
which i just
wrote here so buy and value the first
one is the method that we're using to
locate this element in this case it's an
expat because we just build the xbox as
you can see here
and in the value is the value of the
xpath so i'm just going to copy and
paste
and well it's here but as you can see
there is a conflict because we use
uh double quotes here for this expat and
also here for the value so it's like
conflict so i'm gonna press ctrl z
and i'm gonna use single quotes to avoid
that conflict so now i paste and we have
this
so this is great now we have uh this
element and with this we are supposed to
get the element that is here so the text
title and subtitle here there are
different methods that you can use you
can also use the id or the class or any
other attribute but we're going to use
mostly xpath in this course great now
before we move on here we have to modify
this method so
we shouldn't use find element because
here if we just find element we're gonna
get only the first element in this
website so as you can see here
on the bottom
there are 50 elements that were found
with this expat so
we can navigate here with this uh these
arrows we can navigate from the first
element to the last element and if we
use only find element in singular we're
gonna get only the first element in this
list so this one the one that you see
right now so this one here that's the
only element that we're gonna get and we
don't want that we want all the elements
in this
uh website that all the elements that
were found so to do that we have to use
uh the find elements method so in plural
with the s so
now we're gonna get all the elements
that are found with this expat so great
now we have this and i'm going to set
this
equal to
containers
so this is my variable and now let's
move on here and now that we have this
expat i'm going to show you something
else
that we can do so
let's go back to the element that we had
before which is
this one
and great now we have this element which
is in green
and
we have the whole
let's say the whole container but we
only want the title or we want the title
and subtitle separately so we don't want
to extract them together but in
different variables so what we have to
do is just to open this uh element here
we can click here and open the elements
that are inside this element so to see
the children of this
element so we open this one and we see
that there is this a element
and we still don't get the title and the
subtitles separately so we click one
more time here
and now we have this h2 and this p
and we can see that this h2 represents
the title and the p represents the
subtitle with this we can get the
subtitle and the title separately so we
only have to build the expat and to get
to these elements and to get this xpath
we only have to add this slash which
says hey give me that immediate note and
we only have to write that a because
uh the a is that immediate node that
follows this div so we have to write a
and as you can see here we have this
uh a
followed by this div so it's like a
sequence we have first the div and we
have now the a
now we write this slash again and now we
have to get to this h2 because this one
represents that title so we write slash
and now one more time we write h2
so
this is basically the sequence first is
div then is a and then is h2 and we use
this single slash because we want to get
only the
the immediate node so everything is
perfect so div a and h2 and if we
navigate here with these arrows we can
see that we get all the titles in this
website so everything is perfect so
let's just copy this xpath
and now let's paste it here on pirate
charm so i'm gonna paste it and i'm
gonna comment this out okay now to get
to this uh title element i'm gonna use
driver and i'm gonna use find element so
now again we're right by and we write
value and now we write again expat
and now we paste that export that we
just built so it's here i paste it so
now i write single quotes to avoid any
conflict and we have this
so as you can see this xpath and the
previous one we built has something in
common which is this one that i'm
selecting right now so this is the same
as this
and there is nothing wrong if we leave
this as it is because it's correct but
we can improve the syntax of this
code so what we can do here is to reduce
this containers variable so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to
loop through this
list by the way i'm not sure if i
mentioned this before but the difference
between find element
and find elements is that find element
returns a single element but find
elements returns a list and a list is an
iterable so we can iterate through a
list so we're using find elements and
this returns a list so containers is a
list that we can iterate through so
we write for container
in
containers
colon and now we can put this inside
that for loop so
now we can use this container variable
and we can replace this instead of
driver so we can replace this with
driver so we paste this one
and now we have container that find
element and basically this new let's say
this new syntax
is reducing this container
variable
so now
instead of writing all of this xpath we
can only use the dot sign and
just replace all that export that we had
before so this that represents this
thing
and we can use this dot because we're
using here also the container reference
so this container is used as a reference
for this new xpath so this is like a new
syntax that you can use to avoid writing
a long expat as we had before
great now let's find the expat for the
subtitle so here we have the expat for
the title
which was here
and now let's find the expat for the
subtitle
so as you can see here the expat for or
the element for the subtitle is the one
here that is inside the p tag so this p
tag represents the subtitle and to get
to this p
element we only have to
delete this h2
and only write
p so as you can see now we have all the
subtitles so
the subtitle of this news now the next
one and the next one and this one and
this one too so it's great now we have
all the subtitles of all the news listed
in this website
so now we only have to copy
and paste it here
comment this out and i'm gonna
uh duplicate this line of code with ctrl
d
and now we have this so instead of
writing the whole thing
we can only write just delete this
and p
and let's compare this so first we have
this
and this is represented by the dot which
is by the way this one which is exactly
the same
so then we have a
which is here slash a and then slash b
so this is the equivalent of this
so great now we can delete this and now
we have the subtitle element so far so
good now let's go back to the website
and i want to show you something here we
have right now the subtitle element as
you can see here
but what happens if we only want the
text because right now we have all these
elements selected in green as you can
see it's all this element with the tag
name with that
attribute and also this thing but we
only want the text which should be in in
white
like this one but it's in green right
now because it's selected so what if we
only want the text and not the whole
element so if we only want to extract
the text which is in white here and is
in black in the website
what we have to do is to use that text
attribute so let's go back to python and
to get to the text we only have to write
that
text and this
returns only the text of this element so
we have this whole element that is
in green
and with that text we only get the text
inside this element so we copy this one
and we use it also for the subtitle
great now let's give a name to this
expression so i'm gonna write title
equal to this
and now
subtitle equal to this
so with this we have the variable names
and we can move on all right now the
next element that we're gonna get is the
links of each
news so here
we have each card and let's go here
again to the card we solve we have this
card for example and what we want to do
is to get the link so we go directly to
the website that contains this new and
as you can see the link is here it's
inside the href this is the link so i'm
gonna just click on this link and now
let's wait and as you can see here we
have the
news that corresponds to that card so is
the
all the details about this
this news and now i go back here and
well that's how we get to the link and
now we verify that that's the right link
that we want so now we have to build the
xpath that gets that link so i'm gonna
delete this slash a and slash p
and now we have only this
so to get to that
this href or to this link we have to add
the slash a that we had before
and this is the element that represents
this whole
uh
let's say this whole description
and if we want to get to that link we
only have to use the href attribute that
that's a method that we can use in
python so
let's just copy this
and let's go back to patreon so i'm
going to
use again that container
as a reference and again find element
and here i'm going to use buy
and again we're going to use the xpath
as a method and we're going to write
value and here
single quotes and the whole xpath so we
don't need to use this part of the xpath
because we already have the
container as a context
and
okay now we can get only the href and to
do that instead of writing that text for
example as we did before we only have to
use the get attribute method so we write
get attribute and inside we write that
name of the attribute which is
href as you can see here the name of the
attribute that contains the link is href
so we write href and with this we get
the link so we don't get that whole
element
but we get only the link of this element
so now i'm going to define this as link
equal to and
that's it great now one little detail
that i want to tell you here is that
usually the links are inside href
attribute this is like something that
you're gonna see quite often
and
also the href is inside an atac so you
will usually see that the link are
inside href attribute and also inside
and attack so that's a typical element
that you will see often so the next time
we want to get to a link just look for
the href or look for the eight tag and
you will get to the link fast so now
back to pycharm and with this we have
all the elements so
another detail that i want to mention is
that here we're using find element and
not find elements because here in this
for loop we're iterating through each
element of the list so containers is a
list but container is an element so
here is only a single element per
iteration so we only have to use find
element because it's a single element
great in this video we learned how to
locate all the elements that we wanted
in the website in the next video we're
gonna see how to export all these
elements in a csv file and we're gonna
use pandas for that
all right in this video we're gonna see
how to export all the elements that we
extracted to a csv file so first what we
have to do is to create empty lists so
i'm going to create three empty lists
the first one is going to be titles
and this one represents this title
element
and now i'm going to duplicate this and
the second one is going to be subtitles
in plural
and the third one is going to be links
so i write links
and these are my three lists now what we
have to do is append each element to a
list in this for loop so in each
iteration we're going to append an
element to this list so we only have to
write here titles and use the append
method so this append method allows us
to append each element to the list and
we only have to write that variable that
we want to append so
is like this
titles that append and inside
parentheses that element
now i duplicate this and i'm gonna use
only subtitles and i'm gonna do the same
logic so subtitles that append and
subtitle so this one is the list and
this one is the element and one more
time now links the list
append the element which is link
so this is what we have and this is how
we append each
element uh to the list so in every
iteration great at this point all the
lists are filled with the elements in
this iteration so what we have to do now
is build a data frame with these lists
and to create a data frame we have to
use a library named pandas so i'm gonna
write here
import pandas
as pd
and
probably you have to install this
library so go ahead and click on
terminal
and here just
write peep install
pandas then press enter and you just
have to wait some seconds to install
this library i already have this library
installed so i don't have to wait
anything so once you have pandas
installed you can write this import
pandas spd
and now we can use the library pandas
with this
pd so i write pd
and now i can use the data frame method
so now i can use the uh the data frame
method and i can
open these
curly braces and inside i can use a
dictionary so to show you this much
better i'm gonna create a dictionary so
you don't get confused
so first i'm gonna write dictionary
underscore
or just my dictionary so my underscore
dict
and open here a dictionary so as you
might know a dictionary consists of a
key and a value
so the key
is the one that is here
on the left and the value is the one
that is on the right
so the value i'm gonna set it here to my
variable which is uh titles so our
dictionary is going to have three keys
and three values
so
the first value is titles and i'm going
to name this
as titles too there is nothing wrong if
you set the name of the key as the name
of the variable but if you want you can
change it for example i can write only
title
you don't have to write it the same way
you can change it a little bit or you
can change it completely you can choose
so now i'm gonna write the second
element which is
the subtitles list
so here are subtitles and
i'm gonna paste these subtitles and i'm
gonna write just in singular subtitle
that's the name of my key and now the
third one is links so here links
this is the name of the value by the way
the name of the value obviously has to
be the same as the
the one we want here that is which is
the list
and here i'm gonna write the name of the
key which is link which i can choose
right now great now we can use this
dictionary to create a data frame so
here i copy the name of that dictionary
and i put it inside parentheses and with
this we can create a data frame using
this dictionary
so
just a recap right now first we have
these
lists here
empty lists we fill these empty lists
with all the elements here in the in the
loop
and then now that we have all the
elements inside these lists what we have
to do is to create a dictionary so this
dictionary has a key and a value and the
name of the key we can choose it but the
name of the value is the name of the
list
so with this we have the dictionary and
we created this dictionary to create a
data frame so we're going to write pd
that data frame and inside we write my
underscore ticked and with this we have
this data frame so i'm going to name
this data frame and i'm going to set it
equal to df underscore headline
so we have this data frame and now we
can easily export this
uh to a csv file using df underscore
headlines
that to underscore csv so we're
exporting to a csv file but there are
other options like json and also excel
and html and different options but i'm
going to choose csv
as you can see here and now i'm going to
give a name to this file and it's going
to be headline
dot csv and with this
the file is going to be exported with
this name
so great now to end all of this we have
to use driver that quit
so after we
we struck all this information and we
export all of these to this csv file the
driver is going to be closed with this
that quit great now let's test this out
so we right click and choose run so i
run this script and let's see what
happens so first python is going to open
this driver
uh through selenium and now it extracted
the information and it closed the driver
so the script was successfully executed
and now let's check if we have these
headlines.csv here
on our working directory so here i open
this and we can see that there is a file
named
headline.csv which is this one so we
were working in this folder name
tutorial and this one is the file we
just generated so we double click on it
and we can see that we have the title
the subtitle and the links so now let's
verify if this is correct the first
title is best of the best and the
subtitle says who makes our man cd
versus real madrid combined 11 and all
of this so let's check if that's the
same here and yeah it says best of the
best and who makes our man city versus
real madrid and all of that so
everything was successfully extracted
and we also have the links so we can
visit
any
uh any news that is interested for us we
can go directly to the website and we
can check all the news here without
being distracted by all these images and
all the ads on the website great that's
it for this video on the next video i'm
gonna show you how to do all of this on
the background so you don't have to see
that driver opened every time you run
the script but all will be run in
headless mode
so far we automated this website and
extracted the titles and subtitles that
you see here
and we did this with selenium so every
time we run this code we open this
browser automatically and extracted all
the data that's great but in this video
i'm going to show you how to do all of
this without opening this browser with
selenium but doing this in headless mode
so we don't have to watch selenium
open this browser and do all the
automation but we can just do it in the
background and we can let selenium do
that in headless mode so let's go back
to python and here we're going to add
some lines of code to activate headless
mode
so to do that first we write here
from
selenium.webdriver.com
that options import options this options
is going to help us modify the default
behavior of selenium so now we add here
some lines of code and first i'm going
to write here headless mode so we know
that this is the part that is going to
change so here first we initiate uh an
instance of the options
uh class here so i write options
parentheses and here i write use equal
to options
so this is just a rule of thumb you have
to initiate an instance and this is my
options object as you can see i gave the
same name to the name of this class this
is just like a convention you use the
same name but here in lowercase and this
is my options object so now i write
options and
to
turn on headless mode we have to use the
headless parameter so i write headless
and this by default is set to false so
we don't use headthis mode when we
run this
this script because it's in false but if
we want to turn on head this mode we
have to set it equal to true
so it's equal to true now and now we
have to change this web webdriver.chrome
so in addition to this service parameter
we're going to add another parameter and
this time is going to be options so this
options
has all the default parameters that
selenium works with so selenium has some
default behavior and we can change it
here with the options parameter so i'm
going to set options equal to options
and
there it is so as you can see i
use these uh
name variables just to make my life
easier you can set any other name to
this options variable you can set it
like
options one two three and you can write
here options one two three it doesn't
matter i just name my variables like
this to make my life easier
here too service equal to service you
can use a different name for service
here but i just name it service in lower
case all right now something you need to
know is that we can make different
changes to
that default behavior of selenium but
one of the most
popular is headless mode
later in the course we'll see another
things that we can add to this options
object so we can modify the behavior of
selenium even further so now let's
continue with this uh with these changes
everything is ready to run this script
in headless mode but i'm gonna make a
little change here in the end so instead
of naming this csv file as headline i'm
going to name it headline dot headless
so we know that this
comes from this script which is the one
we're using with headless mode so
headline uh
this dash headless and now it's ready
let's run this script and see the
results
so let's wait a couple of seconds
and the difference with the previous
script is that here we're not going to
open
a browser automatically with selenium as
we did in the previous video but all is
going to be done in headless mode so in
the background here we got a message
that everything was successfully and now
i'm gonna close this one and see if we
have this file headline
headless so i go here and i check here
it says headline
hyphen headless and we have all this
data so it's the title the subtitle and
the link again
but
everything was done with headers mode so
let's verify the first
the first title subtitle and here it
says pep idol watch word diola star
reaction to ben simmons penalty so let's
go here and this is the first section
that we
are working with and yeah we got the
same pep idol virtuolas reaction 2 so
great
you can verify if all that news was
properly extracted i did it myself and
everything is working fine so that's it
for this video in this video we'll learn
how to automate this website and extract
all this data in headless mode
all right in this video i'm going to
show you how to schedule this a script
to run every day or every time of the
day you want so for example this news we
can schedule to run every morning so
every time we turn on the computer
you'll have the csv file with all the
data automatically extract it so you
don't have to do it yourself but you can
schedule when that's going to be
executed so to do that first we have to
convert our pi file this is a pi file
because this is python so the extension
is that pi
and we have to turn this
pi file or convert this pi file to an
executable so we have to do that first
but before we do that we have to make
some modifications to our script
so we have to prepare our script to work
properly
before we turn our pi file into
executable so to do that we're gonna do
some importation so we write from
date time
import
date time
this is the first
the second is import os this help has
like interact with the operating system
for example we can create folders and
other things
and the last one is
sis
i didn't explain you what date time is
this helps us manipulate that date and
time so for example we can extract the
hour or the day when the script is
executed so that's it that's all the
modules or libraries we have to import
and now
let's do some changes so first we have
to use the os module and get access to
the path attribute and then write your
name
and use sys that executable what we're
doing here is get the path of the
executable that we're going to create so
far we have a pi file but we're doing
this for the executable that we're going
to create in the next video so with this
we're saying
get the path of that executable that
we're going to create
and
here we only get access to the path this
is the attribute of the os module and
well this is the directory name and
let's give this a name
i'm going to name this
application
underscore path so my application is my
executable file that we're going to
create and this is the path so we know
what's the path of this executable we do
all of this because
when we work with executable files it's
a bit messy to work with paths sometimes
the path you don't know were
goes the file that you have here so
right now we
export all this data in this csv file
and this csv file is supported in our
working directory this is fine because
we're working with a pi file but when we
work with an executable file things get
a bit messy and we don't know sometimes
where the file is actually exported and
with this we're going to be able to
export a file
in the same folder where our executable
file is going to be located so it's
going to be in the same folder and
we're not going to have any problem with
the path so that's why we do this
next we use the date time
um
this date time to
customize the name of our
file so right now is just headless or
headline headless dot csv
but
if we run this every morning we're not
gonna know which file corresponds to
which day
so for example if it's a saturday in the
weekend and we didn't check the news
from monday to friday we wouldn't know
if this file is from monday or tuesday
or wednesday and so on so just to
customize the name of the file that is
going to be exported
we have to
create a
a variable that indicates which day is
the day when this script or this
executable is going to be executed so
now
to do that we write datetime
that now
parenthesis and this is equal to well
i'm just going to name it now and with
this we have the date
right now
according to my machine or my computer
so now we have to use a method called
strf time
this stands for a string from time and
basically what we're going to do is to
get the time in a string format so here
this null variable is in time format and
we're going to convert this time data
into a string so we can customize and
format this
this time
so here inside you have to write the
format that is used in this uh by this
strf time method
i didn't explain the syntax of this or
the format of this but it's quite simple
i'm going to this website which is right
here which is named as the method
str f time you can go visit this website
and you can check the format that i was
talking about so for example what i want
to create here is a format that is
let's say
day
or
month
day and year
so
i'm gonna extract use this
uh percentage m
i just copy and paste it
then i said i want sorry this was month
with the m then d
so i'm going to struct this where is the
d
it's here so i just copy
and paste percentage d and finally the
year which is going to be percentage
y so this is the year
so with this we have month
day and year as i showed you here so
this is the
the format that we have to use you only
can copy here and paste it as i did it
now i'm going to give this a name and
i'm going to name it
month well just as simple as this month
day
underscore year and i'm going to put
this here on the right
so with this we have this variable and
this variable is going to help us
customize
our
file name
so
now let's go
here let's go uh to this section and
i'm going to use a
f string to customize this string so i
only write f in front of this
string and now to add a variable or to
concatenate a variable i have to use
the
curly braces so with curly braces we can
concatenate a variable so i'm going to
copy that name of the variable and i'm
going to paste it here so i paste it and
actually i'm going to change this name i
want it to be just headline
so headline
high fan and this
so with this we're going to get
something like like that something like
headline high fan
uh tuesday or well in this case numbers
so
1
or 0 1 0 4 2022
something like that just following this
format month day and year so with this
we get this
csv file with a date that we want
and now what we have to do is to use
this uh application path because i told
you that
the path is a bit messy when we work
with executable
so we're going to include this
path here
and an easy
way to do this is just
adding these curly braces for a variable
and just pasting this and adding the
slash and as you can see this is the
typical format we use for a path right
we use this slash and that's how we
uh
put two paths together so we put this
path and this and we get the whole path
but this is not a good uh a good
practice
because this slash is also a bit messy
between operating systems sometimes uh
different operating systems use like
different slash so for example
mac os i think uses this
forward slash but windows i believe uses
this
backwards slash so it's like a bit messy
you can
find some problems if you use this slash
so what we do
is
work with the os module to avoid this
slash so we use um
os
and we use the join method to avoid
writing this slash ourself so what we do
is
write os
that path
that join
and here we have to add the path we want
to concatenate so before i do this i'm
going to create a name for this
um
first i'm going to delete this because
i'm not going to do this you can do it
it's going to work fine but you have to
be careful with the slash
so i'm not gonna do this just to follow
a best practice and what i'm gonna do
is i copy this
and now i create a
variable
file
underscore name just to be more
organized you don't have to do this
i just like to be organized so
file name and now i copy file name and i
put it here
so this is the file name
and now to concatenate this
i'm gonna
write this and concatenate it with
application underscore path
so basically this is the same
we are concatenating this
application path with this
file name so we're not using this slash
anymore or this backward slash anymore
but we're letting this os path join
taking care of it so we don't run into
any issue
so now this is ready and i'm gonna name
this
as
final
underscore path so this is my final path
and this is what we're going to work
with
so
i delete this by mistake but
everything is fine now so now i add this
final underscore path
so i copy this and paste it so this csv
is going to be sent to this path this
path is where the executable is going to
be located so we avoid any issue
with the executable and paths and that's
it with this everything is ready to
convert our pi file to executable file
and then run this executable file
at any time we want
and we're gonna do that in the next
video
okay in this video i'm going to show you
how to schedule this script so you can
run it every morning or every day you
want at any time you want
so the first thing we have to do is to
open up the terminal i have the terminal
here on python
on the bottom so i just click here
terminal and here what we're going to do
is first install a library called pi
installer so pi installer is going to
help us convert a pi
file supply file our python files to
executable so the first step to
to schedule this script is to convert it
to an executable file and once we have
the executable we can
schedule this executable to be run
anytime we want so to install this
library we only write
pip
install
by installer so you just have to write
this press enter and wait a little bit
so here i got a message that i have this
library already installed but it's going
to take you a couple of seconds to
install this library okay once this is
ready we just clean this app and now we
write the following command so we write
pi installer
double uh dash and then we write one
file so this is the command and then we
have to write the name of this
this
pi file so this script in my case i name
it news dash headlines so i just have to
write this name
and i'm gonna press tab and as you can
see here i have this uh
this script
and
i'm just gonna write news dash headline
in one little detail i forget to mention
is that you have to be located on this
folder so on the folder where the
the python file that this pi file is
located so you have to do that on the
terminal here we're right now on the
terminal and to do that
first i'm going to copy this so
i don't lose this
command
and to do that you have to know how to
navigate on the terminal and on the
terminal we navigate with this command
cd which stands for change directory so
if you are not on the folder where is
your pi file this is not going to work
so you have to use cd and then for
example i'm going to use cd to go to the
previous folder and right now i'm on
another folder you can see here this is
the parent folder of tutorial which is
the folder where is my pi file
and i can verify it because if i do cd
i can see
the
folders that are inside this one so i
write cd and then press tab and you can
see all the folders and one of them is
the tutorial folder as you can see here
so to go into this folder i only have to
write cd and then write tutorial so i
have this i press enter and as you can
see i'm not anymore on the football
headlines folder
but i'm right now on the tutorial folder
in this tutorial folder happen to have
this uh
this
um
script that i need so this is the
the script which i need which i named
news dash headlines so perfect so now
i'm gonna clean this and now i'm gonna
delete cd and i'm gonna use the previous
uh the previous command i had which i
copied yeah is this one and well it says
pi installer double double dash one file
and the name of my pi file so this is
ready i'm gonna press enter to convert
this pi file to executable so i press
enter and now we have to wait some
seconds great i get the message that
building the executable was completed
successfully so now to verify this was
successful we have to go
to the folder where this is located so
i'm going here to the left and here this
is my tutorial folder and
in your folder you will see these two
folders one is called build and the
other is this and your executable is in
the dist file so this is my test file
and this is my
python script but now it's an executable
so
on a mac what you can do to
test this executable which i highly
recommend you is to double click on it
and just after you double click you'll
see that the executable will be run but
sometimes when is the first time you
open this sometimes you won't see this
option to open with the terminal because
right now my operating system recognizes
that this should be open with the
terminal but sometimes it doesn't know
so what you have to do is to help it so
you have to right click
and click on open with and sometimes you
will see the option terminal but if you
don't see it you just click on order
and then you have to locate the terminal
so you just click here all applications
then scroll all the way down go to
utilities and here it should be the
terminal so here i'm going to open with
the terminal
i didn't have to do it but i just did it
to
show you how this works so
now i have this uh executable i just run
this executable by
double clicking on it
and here and well the executable
apparently is running and we can verify
if this is successful by going here to
python or actually we can see right here
so we can see here in the folder and we
see that we have a new file
and this file is named headline dash and
here is today's date so 04 28 2022 and
this is the format that we used here for
the csv file
month
day and year so we verify that this file
was successfully created so we have here
the file and if we check the content
we'll see that is the title
and also the subtitle and also the link
well we verify that everything is
working fine and i highly recommend you
to verify that the executable was
successfully created because once we
schedule this you'll have to wait until
the
moment that you schedule to verify
if this is working fine so it's much
better if you test it out right now as i
did some seconds ago
now we're going to schedule when this is
going to be run so now i open up a new
terminal so i click on new window and
here to schedule this executable we have
to
open chrome tab so we write chrome tab
then dash and then e we press enter and
we're going to get this window and here
we have to write a command to schedule
this executable and the command has the
following format to show you the format
i'm going to this website which is
called chrome tab guru and here you can
build a part of the command so here you
can
know the syntax used by this chrome tab
so here
i previously tested that syntax so i'm
just gonna
leave it as
the default parameter so here you see
five asterisk and the first represents
the minute the second the hour the third
day
the fourth the month and the fifth the
day on the week and here let's say we
want to schedule this executable to be
run
at nine in the morning every day so if
we want that we only
uh delete this and write here zero
because it's zero
uh in the morning i mean the minute it's
zero and the hour is nine so at nine in
the morning so this hour is uh from 0 to
24 or 23 i guess
so we have to write 9 and this indicates
is
9 in the morning so it's saying add 9
and here we can also see
when is the next time when this
is supposed to run so it's 28th
which is the date today
then 29 then 30
uh one the next month
and the second of the next month so we
have here we can verify which days this
is supposed to
to run so
this is really good because you have to
be very careful when you create uh this
command because
by mistake you can make it like to run
every minute or run every hour and you
might damage the performance of your
computer so be very careful and check
out that expression that you're creating
here so i'm gonna copy this
and now i'm gonna paste it here okay
this is the first part of my command and
the second is
the
path of that executable file so here we
have to
go here to my folder and we have to drag
this
file to the terminal to get that path so
here first i'm gonna press the i key
to
go to insert mode so here i'm in short
mode and i can type anything as you can
see here so we're in insert mode and
here i'm gonna paste this or i'm gonna
drag this file so i drag just to get the
path so that's how mac os works
so here we have this path and this is
the second part of this command so first
we have to write the hour that we want
or the time we want this to run
and then we have to
paste that path of this executable so
everything is ready here
and what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna save
this command and to do that we have to
press the escape key so i press escape
and now we have to press this column
that you see on the bottom and now w and
q so w stands for right and q stands for
quit so we want to write this and then
quit this chrome tab
now i press enter and
we're going to get this window and we
have to press ok to give permission so i
press ok
and now this was successfully created
and to verify this we have to write the
command chrome tab
dash l so we're going to list all the
commands that were created so i press
enter and now you see that one of the
commands created is the one we just
created a second ago so this is the
command we created and with this we're
telling uh our operating system that we
want to run
this executable
at nine in the morning every day so i'm
not gonna wait until nine in the morning
because it's gonna take too much and we
already tested out this executable file
manually so we know that this is working
just fine so
you can schedule this to be run earlier
in your computer and verify it yourself
or you can test this out manually as i
showed you before and that's it for this
video in this video we'll learn how to
schedule an executable file to be run at
any time you want
okay in this video i'm going to show you
how to create pivot tables using python
so here we have the typical sales data
that we have to work with in microsoft
excel so we usually have to create pivot
tables using excel but now we're going
to create a pivot table using python in
this case we're going to create a pivot
table that tells us how much people
spend in each product line so we're
going to divide
by gender male and female and we're
going to see how much each gender expand
in product line so we're gonna do this
with python and first we have to read
this excel file so i'm going here and we
have to use pandas as usual so i import
pandas as pd
and then to read this excel file we have
to use read underscore excel so this is
an excel file because here we have the
xlsx
extension so that's why i'm using read
excel and not read csv so now i just
have to write super
market underscore sales that xlx
x
and well this is
the name of the file you
i'm going to set a name to this so df
equal to
and with this we have the data frame so
we read this excel file and we put this
inside a data frame so with this we're
reading this excel file so now if you
want we can print this so
i print this data frame and now we'll
see the result and well here i didn't
write the name correctly so i didn't
write supermarket so i write
i write supermarket now and we have here
the data frame and as you can see we got
here the same data that is on the left
but now is here printed in python so
now to make a pivot table
what we have to do is use
that pivot underscore table method
so what we have to do is write df that
pivot underscore table and then we have
to indicate the index the columns and
the values for this pivot table great
and now i'm going to show you the
columns that we're going to work with so
these are the columns in yellow so the
gender column the product line column
and the total column so i'm going to
select these columns so we only see
these three columns in our data frame so
to do that first we have to write df
which is the name of our data frame and
then write double square brackets to
select multiple columns so to select one
column we write
just a pair of square brackets and if we
want to select multiple columns we have
to write double square brackets so
now we indicate the columns that we want
to select so in this case is the gender
column
then is the
i think product line column so i just
copy this one
and finally is the total column so total
so with this we have the three columns
that we wanted so now
i can set df equal to this and now my
data frame will have only these three
columns so if i print this you'll see
that we only have three columns and
these are the columns that we selected
so this is a good practice when you only
want to focus on some columns and you
don't want to see all the columns that
is in the file great now let's continue
with our pivot table so i have here the
pivot table and we have to define which
are the index the columns and the values
so first what we have to do is remember
the goal of this pivot table so the goal
is to see how much each gender is spent
in each product line so if that's our
goal
probably we want the gender in the index
and we want the product line in the
columns and also we want to sum the
amount of money spent on each product so
now let's define the parameters first
the index so index is going to be the
gender
then
the column is going to be
the product line so
i said here product line
then we have the
values
and as i said before this is going to be
the amount of money so this is going to
be total
and finally we have the aggregates
function that we want to apply so in
this case we have to write agg
func and this is the operation that we
want to apply so in this case i want to
sum okay with this our pivot table is
ready and now i only have to set this
equal to and i'm going to name this
pivot underscore table
so that's the name of my pivot table
and well now i'm just going to
put this here and well this is ready and
now i'm going to print this pivot table
so you can see its content so print
pivot underscore table so now i run this
and let's see the result so here we have
our pivot table and as we can see we
successfully built this pivot table so
in the index we have the gender male and
female then in the column we have the
product line so there are different
product line electronic accessories
exports and travel and so on and finally
in the values we have the numeric data
that was in the total column so here we
have this numeric data and well we use
the sum as our aggregate function so we
sum the values in each category and now
to see the content of this pivot table
much better
i'm going to export this pivot table in
an excel file so what i'm going to do is
delete this and here i'm gonna export
this pivot table using to underscore
excel and then i'm gonna set a name for
this excel file so i'm gonna set it
equal to
pivot underscore table dot x l s x and
we can also set the name of the sheet in
this case i'm gonna name the sheet as
report
so this is the name of my sheet and then
we can also set in which row this data
is supposed to be exported so we only
have to add the start row parameter and
in this case i'm going to export this in
row number four and with this this pivot
table is going to be exported in an xlx
file and the first sheet is going to be
named report and this is going to export
it in row number four and by the way you
can also round the numbers inside this
pivot table so you only have to write
here that round
and zero so with this you round the
numbers inside this pivot table so now i
run this so now i should have this file
in my working directory and since i
don't have microsoft excel in my
computer i'm going to open this in
google sheets okay i just opened this
file and well is named pivot underscore
table it's an excel file and i just
opened this in google sheets and well
this pivot table was exported in the row
that we specified and we see that the
sheet is named report here on the bottom
and that's it we successfully created
this pivot table with python and we
exported this into an excel file
in the previous video we used this sales
data to create this pivot table with
python
and now we're going to use this pivot
table to create a bar chart and to do
that we're going to use a library called
open pi excel so first we go here and we
open the terminal and we install open pi
excel so we only have to
write pip
install open pi
xl
so now we press enter and with this
we're going to install this library and
this library is going to help us do
things we will do in microsoft excel
like creating charts or summing values
in columns and more things so now let's
import this library so i write from open
pi excel
import
and the first thing we're going to
import is
load underscore workbook and we're going
to use this load underscore workbook to
read our excel file so the name of my
excel file is pivot underscore table so
now i use this
load underscore workbook and here i
write the name of the file so i write
pivot underscore table dot x
lsx and now i set this equal to
wb which stands for workbook and now i'm
going to select the sheet i'm going to
work with so to do that i have to write
wb
and then open square brackets and then
we have to write the name of the sheet
in this case i'm going to use the sheet
report which is here so the name is
report and now i only have to write
report and this is the name of my sheet
so i set this equal to
sheet
all right with this we have the workbook
and we also have the sheet and now we
can use these two variables to
manipulate our file okay now what we're
going to do is select the active rows
and columns that are in our
sheet so here we have some active rows
and columns and this is determined by
the cells where our pivot table is
located so here we see that our pill
table is located
between a5 and g7 so we have to locate
the minimum row
the minimum column the maximum row and
the maximum column so let's do this so i
go here and now we use wb and then we
have to use the active attribute so i
write active and first let's locate the
minimum column so i write that mean
underscore column
so now i duplicate this
and now i do the same but now with the
maximum column so now maximum column
then minimum row and then maximum row so
now i set this equal to and i'm gonna
set
just names that are equal to this so
first minimum column then maximum column
and so on so
now with the minimum row
and finally with the maximum row
so now we have these
four variables and now i'm gonna print
these four variables so you can
understand much better
what they mean so first the minimum
column and well then maximum column
then minimum row and maximum row these
four variables are going to be useful
when we
make our bar chart so we get
1
seven five and seven so
for minimum column we get one and for
maximum column seven so let's go and
check here so minimum column one so
that's correct because the minimum
column is a which represents one and the
maximum column where our pivot table is
located is g so it's two four five six
seven so yeah maximum column seven so
minimum one and maximum seven so that's
correct and then we have minimum row and
maximum row so five and seven
so now let's check here and the minimum
row
uh is five and the maximum is seven so
this
is based where our pivot table is
located right now because this is the
only element that is in our
sheet so that's why this is our
reference
all right now that we have these minimum
and maximum values we're going to use
these values to create our bar chart so
first i delete this and now i'm going to
import a bar chart from open pi excel so
i write from open pi excel that chart
import
bar chart and now i'm going to
instantiate a bar chart object so i
write bar chart and open parenthesis and
this is equal to bar chart so now i have
this bar chart object
and now we have to do this
first we have to
import a reference and this reference is
going to have the minimum and maximum
value so
i write here comma reference
so i'm going to use this reference
and then i'm going to
put inside parentheses the minimum and
maximum values
okay so first
let's indicate the sheet we're working
in so first sheet
and then we have to indicate the minimum
and maximum values so here i write
min
column or mean underscore call and then
i write
mean column
and i do the same for the order so i
only have to duplicate and add comma so
here i add cool mass but we have to
change here to maximum column and then
to minimum row
and finally to maximum row and with this
we have the four parameters and now i
just have to change the values so
minimum column then maximum column
then minimum row and finally maximum row
so
okay
now these
are the reference but now we have to
split the reference in two so first we
have the data this is the data
and then we have the categories this is
the categories so we have to
create two references so let's start
with the data so first we have the data
and i'm going to set this equal to data
so i write equal to
data and well now i'm just going to
format this
properly
and then i'm going to explain you how
this works so
first i'm going to put this
in one line so you can see it much
better
and okay now we have to make a little
change to this reference and i'm going
to explain you why so here we have
minimum column maximum column minimum
row and maximum row but these are the
minimum and maximum values of the whole
pivot table so here we have the whole
pivot table
and the minimum value as i told you
before is a so one but for the data the
minimum value is v
so number two and the maximum value is
still g so seven
so the minimum column is two and the
maximum is
seven so here what we have to do is
write
minimum column plus one
so here i have to add
plus one
and as i told you before the maximum
column is going to be the same because
it shares the same maximum column with
the pivot table so it's the same maximum
column
and then in the rows the minimum and
maximum row you can see that the
data in yellow has the same minimum and
maximum row
compared with the pivot table so it's
the same
so right now we're analyzing
the area in jello and it has the same
minimum and maximum row compared to the
whole pivot table okay so the only thing
that changed was the
minimum column because it starts in b
so
here we added minimum column plus one
okay now let's do the same but now for
the
for the categories so now i write
categories
and here i'm going to delete this and
let's analyze so the categories are in
green so the minimum column is still a
that's correct but the maximum column is
not
g anymore but is still a so here what we
have to do is write in maximum column
the value of minimum column so the
minimum and the maximum column
are going to be
mean underscore column okay
so now let's see that minimum and
maximum row so the minimum row is not
five anymore but it's six
and the maximum row is seven
so here what we have to do is add
minimum row plus one
because minimum row is the reference of
the whole pivot table so five plus one
six so here i go and add plus one
and the maximum row is going to be
still seven so it's going to be the same
it shares the maximum row with the whole
pivot table
so it remains the same and here i will
leave it as max underscore row and with
this we have the references for our data
and the category just one little detail
you need to know here
i highlighted these two areas in yellow
and in green so you can know which are
the data and which are the categories
but this is the same concept that you
will follow in any pivot table so the
categories are gonna be always on the
left here
and this doesn't include the header so
not this one
and the data
does include the header so in the data
we
include the numeric data which is right
here and also we include the headers so
you have to follow the same concept all
right now let's create a bar chart so
now that i have the references i'm gonna
use this bar chart object so
i just copy bar chart and now i'm gonna
use a method called add
underscore data and we already have the
data so the data is here in my data
variable so i only have to add data
and then we have to indicate where we
want to create this bar chart so i'm
going to create this
in the cell b12
and well with this our bar chart is
going to be created in b12 all right now
let's add a title to this bar chart and
then let's add a style
so first let's add the title so i write
bar chart that title
and we set this equal to and we can
write anything we want for our title in
this case
i'm gonna write sales by product line
because this is what our bar chart is
about so
sales by product line and then i'm gonna
change the style so i'm gonna write
that style and this is basically the
style that our bar chart is going to
have so when we create
charts in microsoft excel we have
different
styles so different colors and different
shapes and we can select here only with
numbers so for example we can use style
number one style number three or style
number five so for now we can only guess
the number and then we can see the
results when we export this bar chart
all right now let's save the result so i
write wb which stands for workbook and
then save
so that's save and
i'm going to sport this as
bar chart
dot
x lsx so with this we're gonna save all
the results in this
excel file so now what i'm gonna do is
run all of this and see the results so i
run this well we got a message of
success but before i open the file here
i made a little mistake here i forgot to
add the categories so we created
categories but we didn't add it to the
bar chart so here i'm gonna write here
bar chart that
set underscore categories and inside i'm
gonna put these categories that we
created so i put this inside and here we
also this shouldn't be here
this b12 shouldn't be here sorry this
should be in another method so first we
add data and we add categories to our
bar chart
and then once this is done what we have
to do is write sheet
that add
underscore chart
and then we put our bar chart here so
i'm gonna write bar chart
and then
i'm gonna set the
cell where we want this bar chart to be
added so i set this
equal to b12 and this bar chart is going
to be added in b12
so
just a recap first we add the data and
the categories to our bar chart and then
we use the add underscore chart method
to indicate where we want to add this
bar chart
okay now i'm going to add just
one more parameter here so i'm going to
add title from data and here equal to
true so we have the title
from data in this uh
in this bar chart so with this our bar
chart is ready so now i can run this and
see the results so i now run this
and well we got this message of success
and now i'm gonna open this excel file
so we can see the results all right here
i open the bar chart file that we
created before and here we have the
pivot table and also we have the bar
chart so this bar chart corresponds to
the data in our pivot table so we
created this using the data here and
also the categories here on the left and
as you can see we got here the title
that we set here so sales by product
line
we also got this style number five so
these are the colors and the format we
have and well we did all of this using
open pi excel and one of the coolest
things we did when we wrote this code is
that no matter how many rows this pivot
table has
our code is gonna work because here we
use minimum and maximum values here so
if this pivot table has more rows
and more columns this is still going to
work because we use references and
that's it for this video in this video
we'll learn how to create bar charts
using open pi excel
okay in the previous video we learned
how to create a bar chart so we use this
pivot table to create this bar chart
that you see here and now we're gonna
see how to create formulas like this one
so for example we're gonna see how to
sum these two values but now we're gonna
do this with python so instead of
writing this formula manually we're
gonna do this here with pythons all
right first i'm going to show you the
easiest way to create a formula in this
spreadsheet using python so here
i'm going to first write this formula so
i write sum and well we have this
formula and now i'm gonna copy this
formula so the easiest way to create
this formula is just writing this in
python so first i'm gonna paste it here
and i'm gonna put this in quotes
and well
i'm gonna here set this
cell which is b8 equal to this
formula so here i write sheet
so first of course you have to read this
excel file so we have this bar chart
that x lsx which is the name of my file
that we created before in the previous
video and then we have to select the
sheet so we have to select this report
sheet
this is the report sheet that we have
here and well
we named this as sheet so now we select
sheet and we select the cell we want to
work with so in this case b
8
and then we write this so sheet b8 and
this equal to
this expression so this is basically
the same as doing this so we have b8
here and we
write this equal to this formula so it's
basically the same
so we have this but now encode and now
to complete this i'm going to set a
style for this cell so i only have to
write the name of this cell and then
that style
i'm going to set this equal to currency
so the format is going to be currency
and well we're going to have here uh a
dollar sign i think
and well
we're going to have the sum and the sum
is going to be in
currency format so okay now let's run
this and let's see the results so first
i'm going to delete this because i don't
want to do this manually
so i delete this and now let's see the
result we should have the same but now
with
python so
i run this
and well we see the result but actually
we didn't save this file so i'm gonna
write here wb
just to make sure everything was saved
and that's saved and
i'm going to export this in another file
so this is going to be called report
that
xlsx so now
i run this and let's see the results so
now we have this file
and well let's open this file all right
i have the file here opened and as you
can see we have here the
the sum that we did before so here is
the formula and here's the value and we
have here the dollar sign because we set
this cell with the currency style so
great so with this we
could create this uh we could make this
sum using python but we did this for
only one cell and what if now we want to
do this
uh sum for all the cells that are here
so probably we want to calculate the sum
for all the cells that are here so now
let's do that so the simplest thing that
you can do is just copy
and well you can duplicate this and for
example for b9
or actually for c8 you can just uh
change here c and c and then you can
write c six and then c seven so that's
what you can do but now i'm gonna show
you a better way to do this with a for
loop so i'm gonna delete this
and i'm going to comment this out so
instead of doing this
manually like for every column you have
we can use a for loop so
first we're going to use these
references that we had before so we're
gonna use the minimum and maximum
columns and rows so here
first i'm gonna look through the rows
that we have here
so let's see which rows or actually
let's see which columns we're going to
use because we're going to
sum
these
columns between b and g so
i'm going to use the columns that are in
this range so from b
to g
and to do that we have to use the
minimum column plus one so minimum
column is a plus one b
and the maximum column so okay let's do
this so first minimum column plus one
so basically this is the
the range
where our data is so as you might
remember from previous videos this was
in jello and this belong to our data so
b to
g
okay so minimum column plus one and then
the maximum column
so these are our two references and we
need to loop through this
uh range so to do that i'm going to use
the range method so i write here range
open parenthesis and then we have to
write the minimum value and the minimum
value is min underscore column plus one
and then we have to write the maximum
value
but when we use range we have to write
always the maximum value plus one
because range gets
this value minus one so it's kind of
tricky i'm gonna show you here but first
i'm gonna use this for loop so for i
in range
and then let's print this
so first i'm gonna print let's say from
1 to 10 so 1 to 10 so you can see what
i'm talking about so then i print i
and let's see here i'm not going to save
this so i just want to show you how this
works so when we print a range from one
to ten you see that we got one two three
until nine so we got the last element
minus one so that's why i said before
that we have to use here plus one so if
we write here plus one we actually get
the number 10
so that's why here
i'm gonna delete this i'm using max
underscore column plus one because i
want to get the maximum column here so
now i'm gonna print i and we can see the
results so here
we got from two
until seven and that's correct because
here we want from b
until g so b is number two and g is
number seven so that's great we got the
columns here so we got from two until
seven great now i'm gonna import
something called get underscore column
underscore ladder and to do that we have
to write from open pi xl that
utilities or actually it's just utils
and then we have to
write import
get underscore column underscore letter
and this helps me get the letter from a
column so i'm gonna show you here
i'm gonna just
right here get underscore column
underscore letter and inside parentheses
i write the i so here if i print i'm
going to print i and then i'm going to
print this
so we can compare
the values so here
i run this
and as you can see we get 2 for the
column b we get 3 for column c and we
get 7 for column g so as you can see
this gets the letter based on the number
so if we give 7 this returns g if we
give 2
this returns b so that's what get
underscore column underscore letter does
and we're going to use these letters to
create this
formula so here i'm going to copy and
paste it so we can see much better what
we're gonna do
so here instead of writing b8 for
example i'm gonna open an f string and
i'm gonna open here
curly braces to make this a variable so
instead of writing b i'm going to use a
letter so here
i'm going to delete this
and i'm going to set this equal to
letter so this is my variable letter
equal to and well this expression so
here we got the letter for example
letter b
and then instead of writing here b i'm
gonna write letter
so
we got here
the letter and the number
so now i'm gonna do the same here in the
formula i'm going to open here this f
string and then instead of writing b
here i open square brackets twice
and then i write letter
[Music]
here and here so we have letter
and well with this we have the letter in
our formula and actually we can do the
same here so instead of b
again one more time later and well this
is done and finally we have to change
the numbers so instead of writing 8 we
have to use reference in this case i'm
going to use the maximum and minimum
rows so for example here we had
b8 and this represents this cell b8 and
this is the maximum row plus one so this
sum formula is always going to be
located one cell below
our pivot table so we only have to sum
the last row of our pivot table or the
maximum row of our pivot table plus one
and this guarantees that we're gonna get
this uh cell that we have here v8 so for
example
row seven plus one is eight so we got
this row eight
so
now let's write this here so instead of
writing eight we have to write
the maximum row
plus one
and well the same goes here
maximum row plus one and as you might
expect the formula is always going to be
located in maximum row plus one so that
always happens
and well then we have to edit this
number six and number seven
so to do this we have to take a
different approach so here let's see so
we sum
always the range where the data is so in
this case
b6 and b7
so here we can say that the minimum
value is always the minimum row plus one
because in the minimum row we always
have the headers and after the headers
is the data so
that always happens
and the maximum row is going to be where
the
wrench ends
so for example this one ends in b7 and
this is exactly where our pivot table
ends
so
we have minimum row plus one which is
this and that we have maximum row so
this is our range
so now let's do this here so instead of
writing
six
i write minimum row
plus one
and instead of writing seven i write
maximum row and this is going to be true
as long as you have a pivot table with
this format which is actually the
standard format for a pivot table yeah
you always have this header and you
always have these categories and always
the data is here so basically this is
going to work
usually so now that we have this
i'm gonna
first
comment this out because i'm not i don't
wanna print this eye and what i'm gonna
do here is print the values so i'm gonna
comment this out and let's see if we did
all of this correctly so i'm gonna i'm
gonna print this
and let's see the results so now i run
this
and well we get here some b6 b7 which is
what we had here before
but now we also have c6
c7 d6 d7 until g6
g7 so this is basically what's going to
be here so
we get all of these formulas
and that's great because
we did this with a for loop and we
didn't do this with uh manually one by
one so great
now that we verify this is correct i'm
gonna comment this out and i'm gonna
uncomment this and actually i'm gonna
delete this because i'm not gonna use it
all right now that everything is ready
i'm gonna uncomment this
wb that save and i'm gonna create this
report so i'm gonna run this
and let's see what happens so i run this
and now i have this file in my working
directory so i'm gonna open this to see
the results all right i just opened this
file and as you can see we have all the
formulas that we created before with the
for loop in python
and well as i mentioned before this is
going to work the code that we wrote
here is going to work as long as this
pivot table has this format but anyway
you can add more columns so you can add
here more columns or you can add here
more
rows but well the format has to be
something like this and that's it for
this video in this video we learn how to
create formulas in our spreadsheet using
python
alright so far we learned how to create
our pivot table how to create formulas
for multiple columns and also how to
create this bar chart using python
and now what we're going to do is
complete this report by adding a title
and subtitle and also
changing the font so let's do this so
i'm going here to the right and well
first we have to import load underscore
workbook from open pi excel
so we read this excel file which i named
report.xlsx
and then well we have to select the
first sheet which is the report sheet so
once we have this
we can
have access to the cells so i write
sheet and then we open square brackets
so i want to put the title here in a1
so what i have to do is write here
a one
and then we can write the title so i'm
gonna
put a title which is a sales report so
this is my title and then
i'm going to write a subtitle in a2
and this is going to be named as the
month so
i'm going to write january so we have
the title sales report and then we have
the month
in a2 okay now let's
edit the font so
i'm going to edit the font of the title
so i write that font but first we have
to import font from open pi excel so i
write from open pi excel
that styles
import font
so now i can use this uh font
so i only have to write font
and then
we can choose the
the font we want so in this case i'm
going to choose arial
so i write this
and then we can select uh bold for
example so i'm gonna
set this equal to true so this title is
going to be in bold and then we can set
the size so i write size equal to and
you can choose any size you want so i'm
going to choose 20 for this
and then we can do the same for the
subtitle so i write sheet then a2
that font so this is the font attribute
and then we can change this using this
font
that we imported and well
i'm going to set this equal to arial and
here you can choose any font that you
know from microsoft excel in my case i
don't remember so many fonts so i'm just
choosing arial
so
then i write bold equal to true and well
size
this one a bit smaller in this case 10.
and well after this as usual we have to
save the results so we write wb that
save and i'm going to set the name as
report
underscore january
so this is gonna be my file and now i
only have to run this
and well i'm gonna open this to see the
results all right i just opened this
file report underscore january and here
we have the title sales report and this
is in bold and well the size is 20 as
you can see here
and we also have the subtitle january
and again it's in bold but now the size
is 10.
so we successfully created this title
and subtitle and we could edit the font
and that's it now feel free to go to our
code and hover on the font class that we
have here so you can see all the
parameters that you can use so for
example strike color scheme size bold
italic and so on
all right in this video we're going to
put all the pieces together and we're
going to convert the pivot table into an
excel file so we're gonna use the three
scripts that we created in the previous
videos so this one added a chart and
this one here
added formulas and this one here added a
title and a subtitle so i put these
three scripts together in this script
that i named pivot to report and well
this is basically the same i just made a
little change here i added a variable
that i named month and well here we can
set the month of the year and well this
is going to be also the month of this
report and since i added this here i
changed the
name of our
file that is going to export it so here
instead of writing report underscore
january as we had before here we have
report underscore january here what i
did is uh introduce these uh current
braces to put this month variable so we
can change here for example
march december and our excel file is
going to have the same name report
underscore march or report underscore
december and also here in the subtitle i
set that month so we have here
in the
report we have the name of the month so
with that our script is done so this is
basically the same
that we have here in number two number
three and number 4 but now with this
month variable and well that input is
going to be our pivot table that we have
here and the output is going to be a
report with the formulas and with the
bar chart and well with the title and
subtitle so now let's run this
and well we got a message of success and
now let's see the result and here we
have the file so the file's name report
underscore february and well we have the
title we have the subtitle here we have
the formulas for each column and well we
also have the bar chart so we
successfully convert this pivot table
into this report and we could do all of
this by putting together the scripts
that we wrote in the previous videos and
that's it for this video in the
following video i'm going to show you
how to convert this script into an
executable file so you can automate all
of this even more
all right in this video i'm going to
show you how to convert this pi file
into an executable so right now we have
our script which is
a pi file and we're gonna convert this
into an executable so we can automate
all of this so first what we have to do
before converting this pi file into an
executable is importing two libraries so
we're gonna import os and we're going to
import also syst
so i write os and then cis so now we
have to create
a path for our executable and to do that
we're going to do this so we write os
that path that dear name and then we
write cis dot executable and this
represents the path where our executable
is going to be located so now i set this
equal to
application underscore path and we need
to do this because when we convert a
script into an executable the path
becomes a bit messy so we need to make
sure that we specify exactly where is
the path where our executable is located
so this is why we do this all right now
instead of writing here uh the
name of the file as we did before we
have to join this name of the file with
the path that we have here so here
instead of only writing this i'm gonna
do this so i'm gonna create an input
path so i write input and score path and
we set this equal to
os
that path
that join and we're going to join the
application path
with
the name of our file so the result is
going to be
the
input path and this input path is what
we're going to read here in load
underscore workbook
so here
we need to make sure that this pivot
table that x lsx is going to be located
in the same folder where our executable
is going to be located so i'm going to
do this later when i create the
executable file i'm going to put this
excel file inside the same folder so you
have to do the same okay now that we
have the input path i'm going to create
also an output path so i scroll all the
way down and here instead of writing the
name of the file i'm going to create
an output path so i write output
underscore path and we set this equal to
os that path that join
so we have to join path again and well
again application path and we join this
with the name of the file
so here we write and with this we have
the output path so i write output path
and we
put this inside that save and well with
this we're going to export this report
file inside the same folder where our
executable file is going to be located
so the input and the output are going to
be in the same folder where the
executable is going to be located and
that's something that we should keep in
mind all right now to customize our
automation even more what i'm going to
do is
ask the name of the month so instead of
just setting the name of the month what
i'm going to do here is
write month equal to and here use the
input function so instead of just
writing the name of the month every time
we want to run this executable file
we're gonna ask the name of the mod so
i'm gonna write here introduce
month
so this is very cool because every time
you run the executable file you can
change the name of the month so it's not
always going to be
february but it can be march it can be
december it can be july any month you
want and all the changes are going to be
seen here in the code so here when you
set that month here
it's going to be the same month that you
right here so that's very cool and well
i'm gonna delete this and with this this
is done so now we can convert this pi
file into executable because we already
set the input and the output path so now
we can open the terminal and well here
we can run the command that converts the
pi file into executable so to do that
first
we have to go to the folder where our
script is located so in my case my
script is named six dot
py2exe and this script is located in the
tutorial folder so you can see this here
and well in the terminal i also have to
be in the tutorial folder which is this
one so once you are in the folder where
your script is located you have to run
the following command
uh
pi installer then hyphen hyphen one file
and then you have to write the name of
your script so in my case six dot pi
hyphen two hyphen e x e that pi so this
is the name of my script
and well in case you don't have pi
installer installed you can
write pip install pi installer well in
case you don't have it but probably you
have this
library installed because we already did
this step many times in this course so
okay
once this is done you only have to press
enter and after this an executable is
going to be created into a folder named
dist so we're going to create two
folders a build folder and at this
folder
and the executable is going to be
located inside that this folder so we
got a message of success and now let's
check this folder and now if we go here
on the left panel we see that we have
two folders the build folder and this
folder and inside this folder we have
this executable and now i'm going to
open this folder so here i'm in the same
folder but now in a different view but
now you can see that well we have the
executable so
to run this first we need to put the
pivot underscore table
inside this folder so we put this file
inside this folder because as i
mentioned before we need this file in
the same folder where the executable is
located so now that we have this file we
can run this executable and to do this
on a mac i'm going to open with terminal
so i open with the terminal and now i
have the terminal and as you might
remember i added an input in my code so
here we have this input so as you can
see is asking me for the month so it
says introduce month so what i have to
do here is just write the month so i'm
going to write let's say march so this
is the name of the month and well i
press enter and as you can see this was
executed so we have here a new file
named report underscore merge dot x lsx
and this has the report with the title
the subtitle the formulas and the bar
chart and well i can open this one here
but i don't have microsoft excel so it's
going to open with the numbers up in my
mac and what i'm going to do is open
this one here in google sheets so i have
this report underscore merge and well
you can see all this data
was successfully created so we have the
formulas we have the title we have the
subtitle with the name of the month i
set before which is march and well also
we have this uh
bar chart and well that's it we
successfully automated our excel report
in this video i'm going to show you how
to send messages in whatsapp using
python so you can send a message to
anyone you want at any time you want so
let's get started okay the first method
to send messages in whatsapp using
python is using a library named pi what
kit
this library allows us to easily send
messages uh in whatsapp so first what
i'm gonna do is open a terminal i'm here
on pycharm and i'm gonna write pip
install
pi
what
k
so this is the name of the library and
keep in mind that i'm installing this in
a virtual environment and i highly
recommend you to install it in a virtual
environment because this library has a
lot of dependencies so you want to avoid
some conflict so install it in a virtual
environment so i'm gonna hit enter and
now it's gonna install so in my case i
have this library already installed so i
have the message
requirement already satisfied but
probably it's gonna take some seconds or
even a minute for you to install this
library all right now that we have the
library installed i'm going to close up
the terminal and
i'm going to import this library
so i'm going to write import pi what kit
and to send a message i write pi what
kit that send
what msg
and inside i'm going to use this
parameter so the first one is the phone
number as you can see here the second
one is the message the third one is the
time in hours and the fourth one is the
time in minutes so for the phone number
i'm gonna write the phone number with
the country code so we write plus
the counter code for example in america
i think it's plus one and then any
number you want
the second one is the
message you want to send and i'm going
to write just test
then
the time in hours so here i write the
time uh i think here is
7 17 in the morning so i'm gonna write
here seven
in hours
and then in minutes i'm gonna write 721
now
in the phone number i'm not gonna write
the phone number i'm gonna hide it
because i don't want to get any message
so here i'm gonna define
a variable just for the sake of this
video which is named phone number now i
write input and here i write
enter phone number so every time i run
this script it's gonna ask me for the
phone number and i'm gonna write it so
here i'm gonna delete this
and i'm gonna just copy and paste it you
don't need to define this variable you
can write the phone number here all
right before running this script keep in
mind that in the browser that you use
you need to log into whatsapp manually
so go ahead and go to your browser
google chrome or safari and log into
whatsapp using the qr
code before we run this code so i
already did this and i'm just going to
run this code and try it out so i'm
going to check 7 19s now so i want to
get the results faster so i'm going to
put 720 so now i run this
and i wait a couple of seconds but first
i need to introduce that phone number
and i paste the number and it says in
four seconds whatsapp will open and
after 15 seconds it will deliver your
message so now whatsapp's opening
now uh it wrote my message as you can
see below on the bottom of the screen so
now let's wait 15 seconds and it's gonna
send the message so as you can see here
it just sent the message which is test
and it did it just without any problem
now i'm going back to pi charm and i
close this one and i'm going to show you
different things you can do with this
library okay you can add more parameters
to this method and you can even close
the window that was open so before we
open this whatsapp window but as you can
see the window is still there so we can
add a parameter in the
method to indicate that we want the
window to close after we send the
message so to do that we only
i'm gonna copy and paste this one
and we need to add two or three more
parameters
first is that wait time as you can see
here the wait time is by default 15
so i'm just gonna leave it 15 so this is
our this is the seconds that
you have to wait before the the message
is delivered so i'm going to leave it as
15 seconds this is not so important but
now we see this one tap underscore
closed so this indicates whether we want
to close the windows or note so this is
by default set to false and we're going
to set it equal to true so i write true
and finally we have close time so these
are the number of seconds that we're
going to wait until the top is closed so
i'm gonna set this to two seconds and
basically what we're saying here is that
we want the tab to close after the
message is delivered and we're gonna
wait only two seconds
so
let's run this code first
i'm gonna just
change the time because
it's not 721 anymore but
i'm going to set it to 725
and now run so it pastes the number and
it says in 18 seconds whatsapp will open
and after 15 seconds the message will be
delivered so 15 seconds here is the same
what we said here this is the default
but we could change it but that's not
important for
what we're doing right now so here
another whatsapp window was opened
and it says here again test as you can
see here
and now let's wait 15 seconds
for the message to be delivered
so
just
a couple seconds more and here it's test
and that window or the tab was closed as
you can see great so
what i showed you so far is how to send
messages to contacts so we can also send
messages to groups so now let me show
you how to do it so
to send messages to a group that you're
part of we only need to get the id so
every group in whatsapp has an id and
you can get the id by going to any group
you want and
choosing the group info section then you
have to tap on the invite via link
option and copy that link i already have
the link of the group i'm gonna use for
this video and if you didn't get it i'm
gonna leave a guide that you can use to
get the id of the group you want to test
so here
i'm gonna define first um a variable
like we did before in phone number but
in this case i'm gonna set this
group underscore id so enter group id
and this is not necessary it's just for
the sake of this video but now
we're gonna use pi
what kit and here to send a messages to
a group we have to use send
i think it's this one send what
msg underscore 2 underscore group
so now the parameters are similar but
instead of phone number
we have to use the id of the group so
here i'm going to set right id then the
second is going to be the message so
test
group
the third one is the time so in my case
7 because it's 7 in the morning and
time in minutes i'm gonna set it to
31.
so here it's basically the same
just uh the only thing that changes is
the id so now i copy group id and i
paste it here
so now we can test this out so i right
click and run this one and now it's
gonna ask my well my phone number
because
i didn't comment this out so just
give me a second i comment this out
and now i'm gonna run this again and
it's asking my group id i just paste the
group id
i press enter and now it says in 49
seconds that message
whatsapp will open and then the message
will be delivered now i'm gonna cut the
video and i'm gonna come back when the
automation starts so now it's working
and it found the name
of the group and now let's wait for the
message to be typed below on the on the
bottom and as you can see it says test
group and the test group message was
delivered to this group great we just
learned how to send messages in whatsapp
to contacts and to groups using pi what
kit